I'm just gonna be honest with everyone
Harry and I are not together anymore
well I hope you're sitting down for this
one
so too hot to handle is golden couple
Franchesca Fargo and Harry Josey have
called it quits who could seem not
coming
yeah the Vancouver native was the first
to break the news taken to her YouTube
channel to explain what really went down
between the two of them he decided to
break up with me because he couldn't do
long-distance anymore
I obviously it was heartbroken I did
everything I could I got to LA I was
there for business but I got there and I
was just trying to work it out with him
and it didn't happen and I was like okay
like if this is what you want and let's
announce to everyone he said that he
didn't want to do that I get it because
there was rumors and accusations being
brought up from people and stuff like
that so he didn't want to validate those
things by really saying that we were
going to take a break and in my head I
didn't want to tell anyone I didn't want
my friends because I genuinely thought
that we were just going through a rocky
period and that we are gonna figure it
out
and when I moved to LA it was gonna be
perfect I genuinely thought that no
matter what we were gonna end up
together I thought we were gonna get
married
so I actually talked to Francesca back
in April about how her and Harry were
dealing with the long-distance
relationship due to Colton 19 and she
even said they were seriously
considering getting married so also
decide it really did seem like the
relationship was rock solid like we were
already talking about getting engaged
and like looking at rings so I was like
listen if this at the end of the month
on the 21st if they announced the travel
bans continuing for another month like
we have to do something about it you
know they being like I won't marry you
you want to marry me of course most
celebrated later but like if that's what
we got to do like 100% now Francesca was
obviously super emotional about the
split and she said she wanted to go
public with the break-up for the sake of
her own mental health and she wanted to
make it clear that Harry is not the
there's a lot of things that I
personally from my own mental health
cannot tolerate anymore
I cannot fake a relationship I cannot
pretend that everything's gonna be okay
I'm deciding to come forward with this
video just a note that we're not
together and we're not getting back
together because we just solidified that
in my own braid there was a lot of
rumors that came up that turned out to
be true and I was getting sent a lot of
screenshots and messages I didn't want
to believe it because how could you have
a wedding ring folder with someone and
how could you propose to someone but
you're also saying I can't be with you
because the distance just it makes me
feel like I was being played just like
sad with myself for letting myself be
put through the situation now obviously
there's two sides to every story
so Harry turned upon himself to make his
home YouTube video and trusting the
break-up I'm not gonna be petty or
through a shame photo reading like I
just don't need to do that there's a big
reason why I had to end things with
Francesca because I was at a very dark
point in my life where there was a lot
of stuff coming at me and she was off
doing anything anyway so from the first
breakup I think we both were very
damaged were both pretty upset pretty
horrific clarity or anything of long
story short we decided to give it
another go knowing that I was still
really damaged and
I was really hurt from before and I
couldn't really get my head around it
I stole Francesca I remember holding her
and holding her waist and I can feel her
heartbeat in her stomach
and I could I could feed Oh
how much she still loved me and I just
didn't have that feeling anymore now the
Australian touched on a few topics that
Francesca brought up in her video
including the fact they would always
argue when they were together when we
will look together will boys on the edge
always we would have the highest highest
like the best place like the happiest
moment in my entire life well with her
but when things were bad they were
really bad so every time we would fly it
would just be the worst and most
depressed times in my entire life but
despite their differences harry says he
will always have a place in his heart
for Francesca but yeah I just had to end
it because number one I knew that if I
continued to be with Francesca it would
end up with her being seriously
heartbroken or me continuing to be
seriously depressed in the relationship
she's a wonderful person she's so
gorgeous
and like a rock star and she's well and
truly out of my league she's a superstar